what's the worst that can happen when
you're 20. you lose what you have you're
20. you've got all your life ahead of
you to restart something else I mean how
exciting is that hey friends and welcome
back to Deep dive the weekly podcast
where every week it's my immense
privilege to sit down with academics and
authors and creators and entrepreneurs
and other inspiring people and we find
out how they got to where they are and
the strategies and tools we can learn
from them to help us build a life that
we love what you're about to hear is an
interview between me and Mark Tilbury
now Mark has an incredibly inspiring
story he left school at the age of 16
with no qualifications and no money he
then had a winding career trajectory and
he took a couple of risks and ended up
starting his first business and now 30
years later he is a multi-million dollar
CEO I always knew at 16 when I left
school I wanted to be self-employed I'd
done loads of different side hustles
I've always liked finding ways of making
money School teaches you to go out and
find a job to earn money but it doesn't
teach you what to do with that once
you've got it in this conversation we
talk a lot about business how to build a
physical business how to build an online
business what it really means to think
like an entrepreneur and the skills
needed to survive in the world of
business and how to make this thing that
we call passive income everyone who's
young has got time to make money I don't
think people are aware of how much time
they have I'm probably going to shock
you here with something
at the moment according to the YouTube
analytics 81 of you who are watching
this on YouTube have not yet hit the
Subscribe button and so if you're for
example in the now 81 of people who are
watching this on YouTube but who are not
subscribed to the channel I would love
it if you could do so and would be
awesome to get that number down to 50
and it would be cool to get like 50 50
sub non-sub ratio just just for fun mark
thank you so much for coming on the
podcast it's gonna be super fun I've
been looking forward to this for a long
long time yeah same and yeah I'm I'm
going on yours as well so we'll do a
link Swap and all that all that jazz
um your story is super interesting and
I'd love it if you can just kind of take
us take us through it and then I'll and
then we'll dive into different points
and I'd love to ask more questions about
it so it's quite a long story it depends
where you want me to start from really
yeah um but obviously I come from a
different era to what is around now
um and I really wanted to leave school
school wasn't great for me
um I wouldn't say I hated it but I
didn't enjoy it is that fair enough I
tolerated going yeah I had um lessons
that I enjoyed like would work technical
drawing Sports all that sort of thing
but everything else seemed to be a waste
of my time I always thought there was
always more out there in the world for
me to do so I thought 16 I can leave so
I will leave and I was told by my mentor
at the time although I didn't know he
was my mentor then that getting a trade
will be your best bet you know whatever
you want to do after that get a trade
behind you because you can't go wrong so
I became a carpenter Joiner and did that
apprenticeship for three and a half
years a couple to join her yeah
like the cabinet maker you might call
nowadays so I used to make well some
nice furniture I used to make but
eventually I got wound up with the job
because they got a really big contract
for making these
um wooden trash bins for Walmart or
capacitor as it is in the UK and I was
constantly making these and that's why I
actually bought that job to an end
because I thought you know I can't
continue to do this it's more to me than
that and it actually pushed me out of
that job which was quite good really in
hindsight um but disappointing at the
time do you think that's still good
advice for people today in 2023
um the trade thing if you think
personally and I think we'll Clash on
this
um I actually think too many people go
to university
um I think I think it's about 25 at the
moment it's something like that 20.
that's quite 100
um and when I was at school maybe 10
when
um so the best of the best went to
University to do the jobs like becoming
a doctor or medical professional like
yourself which you've got to do I
understand that fully understand that
and that is correct but what I think is
a lost part of our generation now is the
people that go that could have become
plumbers electricians Carpenters which
then go on to having their own
businesses within those fields and
growing those out and of course because
of that we've now got a shortage of
those and when you get a plumber in or
someone to do any work for you because
you're a fortune because there's such a
big skill shortage yeah um so I do think
too many go so yes I do like the trade
Road and you've always got something to
fall back on and while you're learning a
trade you're also learning about life as
well because you're meeting so many
different people and seeing how the
world takes and I think that's great for
setting you up if you want to go into
business how would you how would you
define trade
um trades well realistically the
plumbers the electricians anyone that
does anything that takes time to learn
through a proper apprenticeship I'd say
that's really a household trade so
anyone that you you actually phone in I
don't know for example tree surgeon you
know they cost you a fortune tree
surgeon yeah what a tree surgeon do well
pruning the trees and all that okay
there's quite a lot of work there when
you've got as many trees as I have yeah
I mean yeah you're talking three or four
grand for a visit so okay so skills like
that I think are are worth investing in
um and I think a lot of people that do
go to university and please bear in mind
I'm not knocking University because it
has its place and 100 agree with that
um but too many go that could make a
really good career elsewhere like and
earn a lot more not start off with the
debt that they incur by garage
University and I do understand there's a
social element to University as well but
it's a very expensive party for three
four five years yeah so yeah or six
years I think six six years in the
medical case yeah
um so what's something like you know
learning to code and becoming a software
developer through like without going to
University would you put that in the
same category of like learning a trade
like you've got the skill that's taken
you a while to learn you don't
necessarily need to go to university for
it yeah I'll certainly say so because
there's an employer I always employ on
experience as opposed to
um you know getting marks from
University or whatever happens to be or
exam results because I think experience
for me always counts for a lot lot more
than exam results yeah always thought
that way yeah no absolutely it's it's
the same for us like
um you know I think a couple of our team
members didn't go to university and I
didn't even realize until like ages
after we'd had it was like oh oh
yeah that's yeah fair enough yeah it
just seems a bit of a push way doesn't
it I don't know what your parents were
like but I'm assuming oh very much
academics all the way forward it's just
almost a given that you're going to go
to university so I think is there three
rules in your household the doctor
lawyer or failure and that's the one
yeah sometimes people put engineer in
there instead of it but like doctor
lawyer engineer or McDonald's those tend
to be the the options that you have
we're not we're not knocking McDonald's
started there and done well as well so
yeah
um how so let's say someone is I don't
know 16 17 18 listening to this and
they're thinking I don't really know
what I want to do the default seems to
be well for a lot of people or I'll just
go to UNI because quote it's useful to
have a degree yeah um how should how
would you approach kind of if you were
advising someone
and if they were like hey Mark I don't I
don't really know what to do I'm 17.
well one of the factors here personally
I I would say and this didn't exist when
I was younger it's not necessarily a
year out but spend some time doing a lot
of different jobs because doing a lot of
different jobs you do find out what you
don't like so we mentioned McDonald's
there so you could flip burgers for two
weeks if you wanted to learn the ropes
of the McDonald's trade then quit then
go on to your next job learn that job
see what you didn't like from it take
the things you did and then put them
together in the third job you go to so I
think taking a year away to find out
what you don't like is a great way to do
things and then if the choice is to go
to university because you want to be XYZ
that needs that then of course you go
but the problem with going when you
don't know what you want to do is that's
a lot of debt that's a hell of a lot of
debt and that debt at some Point's got
to be paid off and you may never go into
that job or use that degree ever again
in your life so is a bit of a waste I
think for a lot of people yeah yeah
even in the UK where you know some
people would say it's not really debt
it's more like a graduate tax so it's
only nine percent and you only have to
pay off once you're earning more than
25k or whatever the number is do you
think the debt thing is still a factor
that people should seriously consider
um I think so because I think it also
limits their job options as well because
most people that come out of University
feel there of a certain level that you
don't want to earn below a certain level
and you are going to be paying it back
nine times out of ten
um but you also job trap yourself to a
certain degree as well well most people
that I know that have been to University
that haven't got jobs are like well you
know I can't find a job for my
qualifications and you think well that's
because you've studied something you
didn't want to study in the first place
and there wasn't any job opportunities
for that and whoever promised you that
University course was going to give you
a good living at the end of it
essentially lie to you because it's not
there but it is a business University
isn't it at the end of the day there's a
lot of people making a lot of money
pushing a lot of people through whether
it's through the University whether it's
through the accommodation or whether
it's through student units or whatever
it is there's a lot of money being out
so I can understand why people push
youngsters that way because in a way
it's an easy option isn't it if you
don't know what to do you've got three
straight four years of wow I'm going to
University I'm working hard everyone
thinks I am but then the reality will
hit after that so again not against
University before anyone feels that way
but I think a lot that go probably
shouldn't yeah I think I'm I would I
would broadly agree with that I think
yeah in in some schools in some in some
backgrounds it's just you know in my
school like 100 of people went to
University and it would it was like
really weird if you didn't and the same
at my son's school as well I mean my son
every single person in his school
leaving in his year went to University
he deliberately did not go to the open
days of the University because he knew
he didn't want to go and if he went to
the open days then they would probably
coerce him into wanting to go you know
like you can join this team you can be
on that team you can do this the
nightlife's great and he felt that it
would hold him back and I think that's
the bravest decision he's ever made
because if everyone around you is going
you say no I'm not you're actually the
strong one in that situation and he's
now built obviously a business with my
what he built a business before we
worked together but now we work together
on YouTube and everything else that we
doing on the podcast strike it big and
it's it's a fantastic relationship
because of that nice so you um were
Carpenter join Over You said for three
and a half years yeah will happen next
in the career at this point you've been
like 19 ish yeah 1920. but I always knew
at 16 when I left school I wanted to be
self-employed I'd done loads of
different side hustles although they
weren't called that oh yeah oh they were
just
um I used to go fishing used to catch
fish at Dover catch a train the first
thing in the morning for free come back
and pretend I lost my ticket so very
cost effective used to catch lots of
mackerel we used to take them around the
house in the states selling them which
worked very very well as a youngster I
used to buy and sell cars as well so I
was flipping cars that's while I was a
carpenter and Joiner so I used to do a
car a week I'd always buy a car that I
liked so if I couldn't sell it it didn't
matter that would be my car but they
were always escort Mark twos that's the
car of choice and they always sold
and I was buying it for about 300 pounds
selling them between 500 and 600 so you
double your money for a little bit of
valeting and that's all it took during
the week and then someone to come along
we'd park it on a nice estate as well
when they came to visit it so they'd
give it a little bit of Kudos and um
always did very well so always done lots
of side hustles in fact I got to a stage
where I actually ended up selling all of
my time which I don't think a lot of
people understand but you know when
you're being paid an hourly rate at work
and you're you're working every hour of
the day Saturdays I'd work part-time in
a model shop Sunday I'll be teaching
people to fly model helicopters yeah I'd
actually got to a point where I sold
every bit of time I had and we went to
fit um a staircase on a customer's house
and I always remember it's really really
rich guy and I spoke to him and I said
yeah how can you have such a great
lifestyle because this is what I want I
don't know if he laughed or not but he
said you know you've got to get your
money to work for you and I went well
how's that work so he explained you know
about investing and having a little bit
of a money starting to grow in the
background he says if you think long
term you'll do well if you think short
term you'll lose your Investments he
said so that was quite important at the
time to me and at the point where you've
sold all your time
you've got no other way of earning money
you know you're done aren't you you
you're maxed out so uh that was quite a
good Turning Point okay two two
questions on that if I so one is um
were you not concerned about things like
work-life balance and all that stuff
that is fashionable to talk about these
days and very unfashionable to talk
about kind of hustling and grinding and
stuff if you're selling all of your time
yeah how are you approaching that
um well to be honest I was never really
too bothered about finding the girls uh
I'm not the best looking Chef in the
world I understand that but I was quite
a cheeky chappie normally had a
girlfriend and
it didn't work out hard at it I had a
girlfriend finish with a girlfriend had
another girlfriend and so on so that's
just how it went
um and I think a lot of people do spend
a lot of time on trying to find the one
and but I always believe the one will
arrive if given enough time
um so that was fine I had a good social
life I enjoyed my enjoyed what I was
doing and when you're for example
because I love radio control model
flying and that's what my main
businesses are
um being that age and being able to fly
other people's models and teach them to
fly on their models without having to
buy them that was great fun anyway so I
was having fun although my time was
being sold so that's sort of how it
worked but when I did meet the one which
obviously everyone hopefully eventually
does
um I did say to her that you you need to
understand I'm very selfish with my time
and she thought what does that mean I
said well when I have enough time to
spend with you it'll be a hundred
percent you know 100 if we're coming up
to London or we're going out on a date
we didn't have mobile phones there so
it's less interruptive and if you had a
date for an evening it'll be 100 of my
commitment time and everything but in
between that you might not hear from me
or you might not see me and all the rest
of it and she understood that and the
long term Vision was and I think if
you're on this and up front right from
the start then that's good classic
um it strikes me that the phrase selling
your time isn't isn't isn't it is an
interesting phrase like is that how you
were thinking of it at the time or is
that a sort of afterwards as you learned
more about Finance you realize you were
selling your time I think it was
afterwards
um I I realized that I couldn't earn any
more than I was
um because again there's no more time in
the day to physically do it and I think
lots of people get trapped by earning a
daily amount of money and I think that's
what I am worth that's the value I'm
giving so that's what I get
um you can only increase that by giving
more value but eventually your time is
limited and again we'll go back to the
doctor analogy because this is what you
are even as a doctor you can hire and
can't you very very good earnings but
that still caps at some point so let's
say as a doctor you do a bit of private
and all the rest of it I don't know
quarter of a million a year something
like that
you're still capped at that that's it
there's no more unless you make your
money work for you
um now obviously I wasn't at that amount
I mean I was probably back in the day I
don't know 15 20 000 something like that
which was double what I was earning in
my job way over double actually
um so what can I do you are trapped and
I realized it but it was explained later
that you'd sold all your time I like
that that phrasing selling your time I
think it's you know there's that thing
of there's nothing that ruins more
dreams than uh the security of a a
monthly salary or a daily wage
um what's the Comfort isn't it yeah and
I I think lots of people will moan about
that they don't get paid enough
um but they don't want to do anything
about that and that's the crucial point
it's that Comfort stage and when you're
comfortable why do you need to do
anything about it I'm comfortable I can
moan about it about it whine about
it but actually I am comfortable and
that's dangerous position if you want to
be rich you had this then this this
conversation which is with the super
rich guy that you were installing the
the stairs for how did that change
things for you
um it made me look at investing
what I would have liked is someone like
myself or someone like you available to
be able to look up and study because I I
think YouTube has opened up
what the schools haven't been able to
provide and if we'd have had Financial
lessons at school might have been hands
up to go to it because I I've always
liked earning money I've always liked
you know Finding ways of making it but
School teaches you to go out and find a
job to earn money but it doesn't teach
you what to do with that once you've got
it
and I think that's where YouTube has
certainly jumped in
and the whole reason we started the
YouTube was because we were on a skiing
trip and we noticed the ski in France up
on the wall there
um and we're in a chalet and I have told
the story a few times but we're around a
table there was four youngsters I say
youngsters 18 19 year olds maybe a
little bit older than that and for two
hours after dinner all they talked about
or asked questions about was business
and finance and I didn't know where the
time had gone I spoke to my son
afterwards he said look that's two hours
they were interested in what you had to
say I said what are they teaching this
and they went no so you know I think you
get to a certain stage in business where
you think this is all common sense
common knowledge everyone knows this but
actually it's the opposite they don't
and you know they're eager to listen and
to learn and to to move forward yeah
absolutely okay so you so you have this
conversation
um as you're as you're installing the
the staircase what happens the next day
in your life
um well I I left work started the
business
um and we're starting a business as well
again a lot of people turn off on
YouTube when you start talking business
because they think it's all complicated
and difficult and hard whereas actual
fact is the the complete opposite uh
most people I find when I talk to them
think they have to know everything about
business they've got to go to business
school or or do business studies or go
to university to study it and they're
the people to go into business whereas
the reality is we're all winging it I
mean to a certain degree I would say
you'll you've probably done the same
with this business every single day is
trying to mix it up as we go along and
you learn the lessons as you go on and
those lessons sometimes are hard learned
they cost you some money but sometimes
they make you a lot of money but
whatever way it is it's a lesson and you
don't forget it because you've learned
it yourself it's not someone else
telling you that lesson you've learned
it and you move on from that and it's a
great way to be
um I think the advantage youngsters have
now which they don't really see is
everything things a possibility now when
I was at school it was what are you
gonna be
well I do I wanted to be a pilot first
of all I wanted to join the RAF and be a
fighter pilot and drive those fast blow
torches around the sky but I've got the
bins and obviously from there on I that
wasn't going to be a possibility so the
only other thing I was good at was
carpentry and joinery so I I stuck onto
that
but also I'd like to have been a racing
car driver or I'd like to have been you
know any multitude of different things
but that was for someone else that that
wasn't for me you know that wasn't
possible you know that that was a
barrier no you you've got to decide what
you want to be and you've got to decide
that now and you can't have anything to
advance because you're never going to
get there and that was quite a Hard
Knock all the time very very hard not
but that was common that was very common
back then whereas today there's more
kind of possibility in people's minds I
think I think so yeah I mean again you
went to University to study medicine and
now you're into YouTube and social media
and all this stuff and yeah you don't
know where you're going to go but the
possibilities are there aren't they you
know if you had if you were at school
now and you like motorsport for example
and you thought well I could do that and
you've been to the car circuit and you
go I'm actually not too bad at this you
know that that is actually a career path
whether you can follow it or not that's
down to you as an individual but it's a
career path I thought it's just
something yeah racing drivers did yeah I
didn't know when came from it's just
racing driver's job yeah I guess
partly it's it's sort of like two things
but like I think for me I was very lucky
in the sense of you know being born in
the right place the right side of
parents privilege and all that kind of
stuff
but I think also there's an
informational advantage that people have
today that they didn't back in the day
it's like today if you think you want to
be a whatever you can just Google it and
someone will have made a day in the life
of a whatever video yeah and you can
literally see the YouTube channels of F1
drivers and see what they're up to date
today and you think huh that's
interesting or you can listen to them on
a three hour long podcast where they
literally break the break down their
entire Journey yeah so I think that's
like yeah one of the one of the really
cool things and in a way like I've I've
spoken to a lot of people recently who
feel that again to your point the
university industrial complex takes in
all of these like varied and interesting
individuals and spits them out to become
an identical automaton going to
consulting or whatever other you know
accounting or whatever you know
obviously consultant accountants all
good just using that as an example I
mean for you to switch from being in
medical in medicine to what you're doing
now I mean that that must have been a
very brave move
um I think once the business started to
do well it felt less less like bravery
and more like common sense
um and and the tide was already slowly
starting to turn and then maybe in my
ear five percent of people were like I
don't really I don't really want to do
medicine these days I speak to medical
students and they're like 30 of my year
group they realize they don't want to do
medicine so it seems like again I think
with the availability of information and
like social media the internet Etc
people are realizing that the path that
they are set on at the age of 16 at
least in the UK where you start choosing
your yeah a levels and stuff it's not
necessarily the path you have to
continue following for the rest of your
life but 10 years ago if you'd become a
doctor you'd have done that till the day
you retired yeah probably and there were
very few examples of like you know
people starting uh inventing a surgical
equipment or something like that that's
what I imagined I would do I was like
I'm gonna be a doctor forever and on the
side I'm going to try and invent some
kind of tech thing yeah um but even then
that was because when I was like 13 I
started making websites for money and so
I already had that business thing going
on the side yeah whereas most people
weren't thinking in those ways and were
just focused on
getting through the but that's the
entrepreneurial Spirit yeah you know and
I think that's in from a very early age
uh regardless of who you are
um I don't think you can be taught that
um you can be taught business without a
doubt and you can learn business and you
can have a go and you can learn invest
in you can have a go but entrepreneurial
Spirit you can't just say I'm going to
become an entrepreneur you know it's
what you are
how did you so do you think that someone
something people someone can develop
I think um
90 of people can can be pretty good at
whatever they decide they want to be if
they're dedicated enough to it but to be
a hundred percent good at it that's
that's the heart bit and that's the
difference isn't it really yeah between
most people because I think in a way
you've gotta you've got to enjoy it as
well yeah like I was I was interviewing
um A Child Called Marcus yesterday who's
like an Olympic medalist in tennis and I
asked him kind of if you want to become
a professional tennis player what's that
what's the balance between like a
discipline and just sort of pushing
through it and he was like it's just
impossible like unless you've genuinely
enjoy it it's impossible to just get
punched in the face repeatedly yeah
which is what happens when you're trying
to play professional tennis
I mean I chose radio control models was
my main business but that's because I
was so into it yeah and I I was pretty
good at it as well you know I traveled
the world representing the UK team
um and we did quite well as a team as
well we got bronze medals a European
championships and World Championships so
that that's pretty good and that helps
build that business as well so if you've
got a passion for the thing you enjoy
and you can see a way to make money from
it is great but it's no good at just
being a passion because some passion
businesses just go down the pound
because they don't look at the business
side of it first and I was always very
much this is my hobby side of what I do
for my business this is my business you
know and they're two completely
different things you know when you're
doing it as a hobby you can be friends
with everyone when you're doing it as a
business you can't you know it's as
simple as that yeah it's the same
analogy that I so um in my course we
teach people how YouTubers um and one of
the things I always ask people is are
you treating YouTube as a hobby or are
you treating YouTube as a business and
you can't say 50 50 on both because you
know you've got it you've got to pick a
side because that radically changes the
way you approach it yeah if you're
treating YouTube as a hobby great make
videos about whatever you feel like
Follow Your Passion all that kind of
stuff if you're treating it like a
business then let's analyze the market
let's figure out how you're going to
stand out let's like you know take it
treat it treat it like an actual
business person would treat a business
yeah rather than hoping that hey if I
just do my hobby thing it'll just
magically make me money
um so how did you decide that you wanted
to so what was the business that you
initially started and how did you decide
to go down that route uh the initial
business again was right at control
models I bought a shop because the only
way you could start a real business like
that was having a shop I mean I'd done
the side hustle part of it which was
repairing people's models on the side
and teaching people to fly them
um but the next logical step was to to
get a shop so that's what I did
um and from day one it was very good how
did you get a shop like well yeah well
basically I just went I did a business
plan I spent weeks and weeks and weeks
drawing up this business plan I tried to
cover everything I could I worked
part-time for someone so I knew what I
needed to do
um he actually stole my plans which was
a pain to be honest but I wasn't quite
ready to go he actually opened a shop
exactly where I was going to open it
with the same name as well he stole
everything
um
completely other another story but I did
a business plan when I was ready which
is six months following this and on this
business plan it laid out what we could
make what my expertise was where we were
going to do it rents everything took it
to um the bank manager and he turned me
down flat he didn't even give me really
the time of day it was literally well
you've made an appointment I've got to
see you but no okay yeah if I could sum
it up any better than I would but that
was what it felt like to me and I came
out of the bank and I went well this is
either dead in the water never going to
happen or I've got to go forward with it
and try and do something and when you've
been slapped pretty hard like that it is
actually quite hard to see a positive
so I could have turned right I could
have turned left so I decided to turn
right the bank next door next door but
one was Barclays I went in there I said
I've got an appointment with the manager
and they went oh you're not down I went
oh and I definitely it's a 11 o'clock
yeah I'm a bit early maybe that's it no
no you oh we'll let you see him anyway
so I went in and saw him
um gave him the business plan spoke
about and he went yeah I want to back
here he said I'll be your first customer
oh well just like that pretty good in it
that's pretty good yeah I think he had
um a certain amount of money that they
had to potentially lend out to start-up
businesses
um and obviously we had to cover it with
you know the the the property I had and
various other things but it was a yes it
was a definite yes and that was a big
thing all right we're just going to take
a quick break from this episode to
introduce our sponsor which is very
excitingly heal now heal is great
because I've been a customer of Hill for
the last six years and also we've got an
interview with Julian Hearn who is the
founder of huel on this podcast so can
check that out it'll be on the YouTube
channel on the Spotify page and that
wasn't a fantastic master class in
entrepreneurship but anyway we're
talking about heal because heal is a
fantastically complete meal so if you're
like me and you have a fairly busy life
and you don't necessarily make the time
to shop and cook and prep and wash up
like a healthy meal at home which is
obviously ideal then the nice thing
about heel is that it's a great
alternative to an unhealthy cereal or an
unhealthy takeaway meal for example I
particularly like the heel black edition
because this is high protein and lower
carb so for 400 calories you get 40
grams of protein and so this is
absolutely fantastic for workout days
where I'm trying to get my 160 180 grams
of protein in and it's also great
because the high protein helps me stay
full for a lot longer take my two scoops
of the Black Edition powder I like the
banana Edition and The Salted Caramel
Edition I'll mix it up in my NutriBullet
blender thing with water and maybe a
little bit of milk sometimes and then
I'll just sip on that while I'm working
at my desk and that will get me the
appropriate level of protein that I need
it'll get me a decent chunk of
carbohydrates and fibers and fat and
also 26 different vitamins and minerals
which are generally very good for the
body it's also very reasonably priced
like if you want it out it comes out to
one pound 68 per meal ish which is about
400 calories and that's way cheaper than
an alternative would be if you were
ordering takeout for example so if that
sounds up your street and you would like
a nutritionally complete and affordable
and healthy option for some of your
meals then head over to heal.com forward
slash Deep dive and if you use that URL
heal.com forward slash Deep dive they
will send you a free t-shirt and also a
free shaker bottle thing with your first
order I still use my t-shirt it's great
it's nice elastic key it fits reasonably
well it makes me look kind of hinged so
you can check that out heel.com forward
slash Deep dive so thank you so much
heel for sponsoring this episode this
episode is very kindly brought to you by
trading212. now people ask me all the
time for advice about investing because
I've made a bunch of videos about it on
the YouTube channel and my advice for
most people is generally invest in Broad
stock market index funds which is
exactly what you can do completely for
free with trading 212. it's a great app
that lets you trade stocks and funds and
ETFs and foreign exchange if you really
want to and one of the great things
about the app is that if you're new to
the world of investing you can actually
invest with fake money you don't have to
put real money in they've got a practice
mode where you invest fake money and
then it actually tracks what the market
is doing in real time so you can see had
I invested 100 pounds into this thing
what would my return have been X weeks
or X months further down the line once
you've got some comfort with that then
it's super easy to deposit money into
your trading tube into account you can
use Apple pay like I do initially or you
can use a direct bank transfer and then
once the money is in your trading 212
account then you can invest it in
basically whatever you want the other
really cool feature about trading 212 is
their pies feature so what you can do is
you can follow people who've created
investing pies for example someone might
have a pie where I don't know 30 of this
apple and 20 is Tesla and 10 is the S P
500 and you can follow people on the app
and see what pies they've created and
you can see the performance of those
pies and then you can just copy and
paste a particular pie into your own
account and so that means like let's say
you've got 100 pounds to invest and
you've put 50 of it into the S P 500 but
you want to be a little bit more
experimental with the other 50 pounds
you could invest it into a pie where
someone else is generally a pro or
someone in their bedroom who just loves
the markets has already done all the
homework for you the app also lets you
Auto invest which is a great thing
because then you can automatically
invest a percentage of your paycheck
into the thing every month and so if you
haven't yet started when the best
nothing and you want to give it a go
then you can download the app on the App
Store and if you use the coupon code Ali
Ali at the checkout that will give you a
totally free share worth up to 100
pounds it's available on iPhone and
Android and you can check it out by
typing in trading 212 into your
respective App Store so thank you so
much trading212 for sponsoring this
episode like my brother is a tech
startup founder and so I'm familiar with
that side of things where they've got
like Venture Capital backing yeah but I
just never really clocked that you can
literally walk into a bank with a
business plan
on a piece of paper and ask them for
money is is that how it works I'm not
sure you get it now yeah um but back
then certainly it was a business plan
okay I think when you had managers back
then the managers of a branch would have
you know the final say over quite a lot
of things nowadays it would probably go
for all sorts of committee and different
things but yeah it's literally a
business loan it was a startup loan it
wasn't for the amount I needed even with
what I had it wasn't enough but if the
business was successful enough for the
first two months it would be enough
and uh that that's the way I worked it
and first day when we opened up I was so
skinned I had nothing yeah I didn't even
have enough fuel to get home I took a
sleeping bag and put in the back of the
van I had because if I didn't take any
money I wasn't able to get home that
night wow but that's full commitment
isn't it yeah and if you're gonna do
anything commit yeah
because then there's no option it works
or it doesn't but you're gonna do as
much as you can to make that work we're
not worried that you're gonna like lose
the house and like all of the fears that
would yeah actually I was 20. what's the
worst that can happen when you're 20.
this is the thing I can't seem to get
through to a lot of people what's the
worst thing
you lose what you have you're 20. you've
got all your life ahead of you to
restart something else I mean how
exciting is that
it's brilliant
you know everything's on the line
did you have that perspective when you
were 20. I feel like when I was 20 I was
like oh if I lose everything if I
get kicked out of medical like suddenly
my life is over yeah but I couldn't see
it going wrong okay but it was exciting
so it's that excitement is what you want
and that drives you on and we had a
crack in day yeah you know I say that
now it's just over a hundred pounds we
took just over and to this day
and this is another thing in retail that
amazes me we've never ever had a day
where we've taken less than 100 pound on
a day we've opened ever even in the
early days
um and what amazes me is people have to
decide to come to your shop particularly
back then no internet no eBay all that
sort of thing so they've got to come to
your shop make that active decision to
come in and buy something
and uh I always thought you guys have a
day when no one decides to come to your
shop haven't you but we never have
quite amazing isn't it that's amazing um
oh what okay I've got a friend who's
super into
um Burgers he just loves Making burgers
makes burgers for his friends and he
says one day I really want to open like
a burger shop or like a burger van or
something like that
if that person was on your ski trip
being like hey Mark how do I how do I
turn this into a business what would be
the steps that you would follow today
assuming you can't just walk into
Barclays and be like hey can I have a
loan well the problem with food is 80 of
food Ventures fail okay so it's a pretty
bad statistic and particularly
restaurants
um so the best plan of attack is to be
the 20 not the 80 straight away so there
you go that's the best advice you can
have because that's the that's the one
that's going to win you've got to have
something a bit different as well and
again with Burgers it's very difficult
isn't it because you would think well I
would I'm not into Burgers
um but you would think everything's been
done
and then you look at
um one Burger outlet that we went in in
the states In and Out Burgers all right
the simplest menu you ever did see okay
so there's three different options
they're just the same Burger made in
three different ways and they were
absolutely flat out my son who's sitting
over there absolutely loved it kept
taking me back to this place I was like
guys I found it I did a chicken burger
as well it'd be great but because I
specialize and their menu is so small
you know people know what they're going
there for and they do a very very good
job of it so I would probably say to
anyone that's going to start and do a
burger van or something like that make
it simple and make it so you can repeat
what you do and when someone comes back
the next week because they enjoyed your
burger make sure it's just as good it's
exactly the same as it was the last time
they had it because the worst thing you
can do
is making this wonderful burger and then
the next week I'm going to cut down on
the cheese I'm going to cut a little bit
thinner I'm gonna just you know I'm
gonna now start portioning the sauce a
little bit less because these are key
savings to make my business work better
and put more profit on my own margin but
as soon as you start destroying that
product or or bringing it down from what
people like it just gets worse and worse
and worse and you might get a third
visit if you won't get a fourth you know
the second visits because they enjoyed
the first one the third visit was
because they thought the second one well
maybe you made a bit of a mistake but
I'm still after that Ultimate Burger I
had the first time I came I think I'm in
a fourth time for something that wasn't
as good as the first time
so for a business like that that
requires some level of startup Capital
how would you approach finding the money
assuming you don't have Rich parents to
give it to you the three F's friends
families and fools
okay because they're out there aren't
they yeah why why borrow it from
somewhere where you don't where you've
got to pay that interest back so those
are your free places to start with If
You Get Enough from that then you can go
to the banks the banks will give you
some money without a doubt so then you
can go that way I've never gone to a
venture capitalist ever I've never done
fundraising never gone down that route
obviously some businesses need it
because they have to go through this and
I hate this word burn stage burn stage
well we're then burn into money yeah you
know trying to build that brand yeah you
know if you've got a good brand it
should pretty much Start organically
growing
um so I hate a burn stage and people
that tend to
um raise money in that way do 10 things
I've got plenty of money we can do that
we can do that before you know it's gone
so a lack of money or certainly a small
amount of money at the start is actually
a bit of a superpower because it makes
you make the most of all your free
advertising everything that's available
to you to make you know the best
decisions from so it depends what it
needs I mean if it's a startup Burger
van how much can that really cost I mean
you need a van you need to adapt it do
it yourself if you can you've got your
recipe you've got your menu
ten fifteen thousand find a pitch
nowadays you're more likely to have to
pay for a decent pitch but back in my
day you'd have just wheeled up wherever
you wanted to and put your sign out yeah
but just keep turning up keep doing it
yeah you know it's uh it's all doable
but uh you know a lot of people will put
excuses all along the way of course yeah
yeah I think especially for like this is
probably why I really like you know when
when people ask me oh you know I want to
get rich what do I do often I'm like
okay well there's a lot of books you can
read and stuff but like if you learn how
to code that is a very good way to get
into the business thing because almost
every software business that you start
does not need startup Capital you can
get your ten thousand dollars of Amazon
web services credit for free you don't
need to spend 15K on a van
um and you can almost kind of be
profitable from day one you're not in
that burn stage where crap I've just
spent 15 grand and now I need to recoup
that over the next five years and then
I'll become profitable and the other
beauty of a digital product is you can
obviously be anywhere in the world
producing that digital product so your
overheads can be cut to an absolute
minuscule amount if you want to and you
can be in a beautiful part of the world
for very little money producing your
product so yeah digital products are
fantastic yeah yeah similarly I get I
get emails from people being like hey
can you do a video about passive income
ideas from Pakistan and I'm like well no
because I'm not in Pakistan right now
but also like passive income ideas from
Pakistan is the same as passive in
commodities on the internet anywhere
else because the internet is not
localized so I think there's definitely
something to be said for using the power
of the internet which wouldn't have been
a thing back in your day to start
businesses that can benefit from that
location Independence and also the scale
and the trouble you mentioned passive
income most people's definition of that
is it's a business that's going to give
me money I haven't got to do anything
but the the real definition of a passive
uh business is it's going to cost you
either time or money or combination of
the two so whatever way you look at it
you know it's not really passive
you know it's got to have that initial
investment of time or money or both
um
let's go back to this guy that you were
um installing the stairs for so it
strikes me that there are two directions
you could you could have gone from there
the guy's saying to telling you you know
make your money work work for you
and I'm going to use the terminology
from MJ DeMarco who might be familiar
with where it's like you can go down the
slow lane approach or the fast lane
approach and the slow lane would be okay
I'm making I don't know 2K a month my
costs are 1.8k I can save 10 of my
paycheck every month and I can put it
into the S P 500 yeah and someone I
watched a video on YouTube from Ali
Abdullah telling me that Warren Buffett
says you should invest in the S P 500
great yeah that money is growing by
seven percent here by the time I'm 55 I
should it should be worth a million
versus
I'm going to take that spare 200 quid
and I'm going to use it to start my own
business
what do you think about those two
different well I use the combination of
the two
um I've always put away approximately 10
of what I earn into an index fund always
from from about 18. nice so I'm sorted
aren't I you know because you know that
that was always going to become a big
amount I can draw down on it now if I
want but of course why would I I've got
10 years of hopefully amazing growth and
but I've also gone hopefully part way
down the fast lane
um and that is obviously open in a
business investing in myself investing
in the business and pushing that forward
um there's lots of hurdles along the way
though you know like shops were a great
thing to have when I started you know
the model shops and we you know built
those shops up to various you know
several different shops
um but then of course the internet hits
and then having brick stores isn't the
way to be so you've got to adapt that
business
um so now we're talking 35 years on from
when I start did and we're still in
business doing a similar thing but we're
doing it in a completely different way
so I think an entrepreneur sees
um answers as opposed to hurdles or they
might see a hurdle they get over it and
move on you know they don't get stuck by
it and that's what we try and do so 35
years ago when you started the business
were you thinking you know 35 years
later I'm still going to be doing this
so we're more like short-term in Europe
um I would say it was a lifetime sort of
uh business at the time definitely
um because I think most passion
businesses are
um I think the ones that aren't and the
ones with the exit strategies are more
Tech type businesses
um
and if I was advising your friend with
the berica van
um I would probably say that the the
main thing to focus on is your exit to
be perfectly honest where where is it
going where's your finish stage because
if you don't have an exit stream
strategy you haven't got anything that's
sellable
so a few years back probably 10 years
back I decided that wasn't something I
had an exit strategy at all to the
business I was in and so I've made it or
adapted it so at any point should I now
want to sell it I have a role in exit
strategy so year on year on year and
it's now a turnkey business as opposed
to being fully dependent on myself which
it was obviously we had staff but you
know you take take me out of it 10 years
ago it wouldn't have operated but now it
will operate very well with the staff
that we had again uh refer to yourself
similar to yourself you have a very good
team behind you and once you have a very
good team then the business can roll on
a daily basis yeah I think the thing for
me is you know people uh that was in uh
Miami earlier this week everyone's there
was like multi-million 10 million
agencies and talking about selling to
private equity for 20x profit and I was
just like yeah I don't think I have an
extra strategy but for me and this
business I didn't really think of his
business but I feel like I don't really
want an exit strategy
um the for me making YouTube videos
interviewing people writing books and
stuff that's more like a lifestyle
Choice rather than a quick business or
similar to my lifestyle yeah
because the enjoyment was there so you
know it rolled and rolled and the
enjoyment came yep every day yeah that's
a great thing with enjoying what you do
isn't it yeah it's a fun time you know
you are going to work and yes you do
work hard but the work you do you enjoy
so it's you're rewarded every day yeah
absolutely and I guess further down the
line if I did decide okay this is no
longer that fun let's now let's maybe
figure out an extra strategy license the
IP there's you know there's then things
that you can do to build a cell as it
were
um
just to take things back to complete
Basics what is a business if someone's
listening to this and they're like I
feel like the word business is you know
we're talking about exit strategies you
know I just threw out you know 20x
profit for someone who doesn't
understand what's going on it's like the
word business can feel very daunting so
how would you break that down like most
simply well if you want to boil it down
to really the brass tanks it's buying
something and selling it for a profit
that's the brass tax of business isn't
it really uh or producing something and
adding value to it selling it for a
profit so it can be as simple as a side
hustle and the reason side hustle is so
popular I think on YouTube is because
people don't think it's a business where
of course it is a business it's only
when you go into scale that the problems
obviously come but a side hustle
essentially is a business and no one's
scared or very few people are scared of
a little side hustle yeah but they're
scared of doing a business yeah that's
true but really they're the same thing
just slightly bigger
um a lot of people think business is
when you start employing people of
course it's not is way before that but
the employment thing is a is a big
Trigger or a hard point to get over when
you get to that stage so when you're
selling or when you're repairing model
airplanes on the side would is that a
business
um I would say it is okay because you
become known for it if you're known for
something and that's what you do I would
say well it is a business because it was
the start of a business as well without
that the business wouldn't have started
it wouldn't have had the capital to be
able to start you know what I was
earning from that you know made me more
money so if you take
um the repair in people's models
scenario I was working part-time in a
model shop so I had quite a lot of
customer base from that I wouldn't go
out and teach and fly that crash their
model it would need repairing that or if
they didn't crash it I would be able to
suggest how we could make that model fly
better and my specialty was radio
control helicopter so there was always
upgrades always so or what you need on
that you need a new metal head or the
titanium tail boom or whatever happened
to be that would improve it for you and
it'd be like I don't know how to do that
well leave it with me when we come back
for a lesson next week I'll have it all
done for you so you've got the spare
parts I was buying with a trade discount
because I'm working in a store so that's
great you sell it full price you've got
the repair costs and labor maybe an hour
always charged to the hour that's always
a good tip you know if it takes you half
an hour your minimum's an hour
and you had you supplied it back they
were going to be there the following
weekend because they wanted to pick up
their pride and joy so they're not going
to not turn up for their lesson so it's
actually that is a business yeah you
know and it's only then scaling it
that people have the issue with ah
interesting
yeah I like that definition of business
it makes it feel a lot less daunting
because I think even like before
I think yeah for me when I was doing my
web design type stuff
I was we are really thinking of myself
as a business I or even trying trying to
act as if I was a bigger agency than I
actually was there's one manager for
hoping people give me work
but yeah the word business does seem
very daunting to people and thinking of
it as this you're you're taking a thing
you're buying a thing you're adding
value to it and you're selling it for
profit it's strange isn't it really also
the other hard thing when you're doing
it as a side hustle is understanding
what you're worth as well because your
value you're adding quite often is a lot
more than you're charging for as well so
if you're charging an hourly rate of 30
pounds 40 pounds fifty per hundred
pounds yeah and you are booked out yep I
mean it's obvious to look at that now
and go well it's worth more than that I
should have charged more but at the time
you think you're charging about the
right amount and that's why you're busy
but you know you could you could let's
say you double the amount you charged
and you lost a quarter of the people
you're earning more money yeah and
you're working less time
and that's quite a hard lesson to learn
when you're starting out in business
why do you think people have such a an
aversion to
price and money
um
they forget political
um I think before
um
I'll say it before Margaret Thatcher
came into Power because I always blame
her a little bit for everyone trying to
get the best price on everything before
that I think it I always felt it was
what something cost was what something
cost you went and you bought it and I
think she brought a lot of americanisms
in where you you know you question the
price and you ask for a discount and all
that sort of thing so I would say that's
where that stemmed from and of course
now it's a worldwide market with the web
and the web
in certain aspects is a race to the
bottom on price particularly with the
likes of Amazon and all the rest of them
with their bolt buying power and not
having to declare profits and all the
rest of it
um so people are always after a bargain
now and I think that I would say that's
where it started in my opinion before
then it was you paid the price and like
I think the there's also an interesting
phenomenon on the other side so my my
singing teacher Josh it's charging like
I'm glad you're having lessons by the
way
oh yeah I need it
um my singing teacher Josh it was
charging like I think like 30 quid an
hour initially and is ridiculously
qualified it literally has performed in
Broadway musicals and has done TV work
and is amazing I was like why are you
charging 30 quite an hour and he was
like oh I don't feel right I don't feel
right charging 35 or 40.
even though his business is not
particularly profitable because we were
talking about it I was like dude surely
just like double the prices because you
know that thing yeah maybe you lose 25
of your customer who cares you double
your prices do you can always come back
yeah
and he felt like he he said he felt bad
increasing the prices because he felt
like it wasn't worth he wasn't worth it
even the people were willing to pay do
you see that kind of thing at all
amongst amongst people that you talk to
I think a lot of people under charge I
mean I used to race
um cars full-sized cars it was a great
hobby by the way if you ever get into it
it's fantastic
um I don't now I sponsor someone in the
British touring cars but I used to race
cars and I used to have a guy used to do
a lot of the mechanic him for me on that
car and I'll deliver it to him and tell
me what he's done and he said 75 quid
sorry about that and I think God
expecting 200 pounds on that bill and
like I have 124 really yeah yeah you
have it he went out of business he was
in business as a mechanic for about four
or five years went out of business and I
know why he went out of business I told
him why he was gonna go out business and
he wasn't charging enough
you know but he was so afraid and I
don't know why people don't try because
trying to charge a little more is an
experiment in business isn't it and you
push it to as far as you can because you
can only make that profit once from that
customer you know you don't want to rip
anyone off I would never
say go and rip people off but you're
providing value and it's what you put as
that value
and that's an important amount of money
if your customers think what you're
doing is worth more than you're giving
them I mean why does anyone listen hmm
yeah why why do you think people have
that fear that fear of charging more
I think they think they'll lose everyone
or feel they're ripping someone off yeah
they don't value their skill enough
which is a shame
because skills take a long time to
establish so again if you want to boil
it down to learning to fly a Model
helicopter that to the stage from from
getting an RC helicopter all those years
ago and they were hard to fly I mean
they didn't really fly they beat the air
into submission basically but to learn
to fly Model helicopter took me a best
part of a year to get to the stage where
I could teach now some people it took a
lot longer than that but for me it took
a year that is a lot of flying time
parts spare parts when you break the
model that's a lot of investment isn't
it and you've got to get that back
so it's got to be worth something yeah
absolutely I think when I first started
charging for for our course about 200
years ago I was so scared I was like oh
I'm gonna people are gonna think I'm a
sellout like I've built an audience off
of free content and now I'm gonna charge
for something oh my God and then like
it's kind of expensive so like the
people in modernity can't afford it are
going to think I'm a terrible person and
there were all these fears I had around
money and I think what was underlying
that was the idea that money is evil and
making money is bad and making money by
charging people for things is worse and
I just had there was a lot of untangling
I had to do was that something that
you've you've come across I've never
struggled with it really
um with I mean you get people knocking
Drop Shipping don't you oh you've bought
that from Alibaba for ten dollars and
you're selling it to me for thirty
dollars that's a rip-off well what do
Walmart do what do Sainsbury's do what
do all these companies do they buy for a
low price they sell for a high price and
the value they put in between is why
they can get that profit why why would
you say that's a ripoff it's not a
rip-off that's what I want to sell that
product for so why should you struggle
with that yeah if no one wants to buy it
then then you then I've got a problem
because I can't earn the margin I need
to survive in business I either I've got
to change my business model or I've got
to look at my margins and see if I can
you know rely on less
but there's always a figure that you
can't do less than it's just not worth
your while if you're not earning money
what is the point
and the thing with courses
I mean I I only provide free content as
you're aware
um and I don't have a problem with
courses I think courses such as your own
and others are very good and provide
excellent value but of course there is
the other side of it and you know the
people that that produce better courses
and they they are a rip-off without a
doubt you know so it's very hard to
justify the cost of yours but you know
the effort that's gone into what you're
producing
again that's the value you're adding and
if that's good value then you should
never be ashamed to charge for it ever
the fact that you can now sell millions
of a digital product that's immaterial
you still put that value in
yeah yeah I think another thing that I
have appreciated over time is sort of I
think cost based versus value-based
pricing where I think people are in are
often thinking oh this only took me half
an hour or therefore I'll charge based
on that versus that half an hour has
added 500 Grand in sales to this this
company that you've just tweaked the
headline for so let's charge based on
the value we've provided rather than the
cost it costs us to do the thing yeah
well it goes to like a story of the guy
that fixes the computer I mean a guy
goes to this massive computer place
let's call it IBM and they don't know
what's wrong with their big blue
computer or whatever it was called at
the time and he turns up he looks around
and he takes out a component puts a new
component bam it goes into life and he
says there's my invoice 20 000 pounds
and they said twenty thousand pound
you're only here five minutes yeah but
it took me years to know what component
to take out to make that work that's my
value do you want to take it back out
yeah no right okay twenty thousand
pounds hopefully and also if that
computer is printing them like a hundred
thousand pounds a minute it's like you
know exactly to them there's five
minutes or worth 500k yeah so but you
know that that knowing that component
might have taken him yeah
fifty thousand hours of gaining
knowledge to know that's the component
that you need to change so they're
actually paying a proportion of that
fifty thousand hours of learning yeah
true I'm paying for it back
um so what is what is your model
business do these days what does it look
like what does it look like
um at the moment we have um a couple of
shops
um that sell direct to public uh they
also sell on eBay and also via the
website
um there's still a very big enjoyment
for me and if I get time I'm behind the
counter from time to time not not as
much as I'd like to be but I still get a
kick out of of selling a product
particularly if someone comes in and
they don't know what they're buying and
I can explain yeah ask them yeah who
they're buying it for what they want it
to do and all the rest of it and I can
explain the best package and they go
yeah I'll have that that's that's that's
quite a kick you know you you know it's
really nice and you know they're gonna
love the product and that's brilliant so
that's the shop side of the business
then we also have a design import
manufacturing and distribution business
as well
um and we manufacture in China and also
in Vietnam and they're my own designs
that we we manufacture
um and the best selling one of those
designs is a model called the riot which
is a model airplane I designed that when
I was 14 in a geography lesson as well
well yeah it took me years to make it
and the reason it took so long is
because there used to be a product
leader in the market and I had a deal
with him because I knew he was getting
quite old that when he retired he would
pass those desire rights for me and I'd
continue that brand and he'd have a
royalty
um but liking business always a bit of
backstabbing some one somewhere down the
line and he passed it to someone else
and I said well yeah listen I said well
I promised that to him before I said
well you could have let me know but I
had all these models that I designed as
a kid and I went right here we go let's
let's get them manufactured and now we
are more prolific than the models we
would have taken on
because they're better of course
and I designed those because I couldn't
afford the kits when I was a Youngster
you know so I'd use the woodwork lessons
well after school they had a woodwork
lesson I'd cut out the sides of the
models and use the technical drawing
tables as well to do the final designs
you know use what you've got available
for free a bit like where you start a
business use your advertising tools that
are free use everything you can don't
just go how much does this cost to
advertise and give them all your money
you know it's about using what you've
got
this episode is very kindly brought to
you by wework now this is particularly
exciting for me because I have been a
full paying customer of wework for the
last two years now I discovered it
during you know when the pandemic was in
the on the verge of being lifted and I'd
spent like the whole year just sort of
sitting in my room making YouTube videos
but then I discovered wework and I was a
member me and Angus my team members we
were members of the wework in Cambridge
and they have like hundreds of other
locations worldwide as well and it was
incredible because we had this fantastic
beautifully designed office space to go
to to work and we found ourselves like
every day just at nine o'clock in the
morning just going to wework because it
was a way nicer experience working from
the co-working space than it was just
sitting at home working these days what
me and everyone in my team has is the
all access pass which means you're not
tied to a specific wework location but
it means you can use any of their
several hundred co-working spaces around
London around the UK and also around the
world and one of the things I really
love about the co-working setup is that
it's fantastic as a bit of a change of
scenery so these days I work from home
I've got the studio at home but if I
need to get some focused writing work
done and I've been I'm feeling a bit
drained just sitting at my desk all day
I'll just pop over to the local wework
which is about a 10 minute walk from
where I am I'll take my laptop with me
I'll get some free coffee from there
I'll get a few snacks and it's just such
a great Vibe and you get to meet cool
people I've made a few friends through
meeting them at wework and it's just
really nice being in an environment
almost like a library but kind of nicer
because there's like a little bit of
soft music in the background and there's
other kind of startup Bros and creators
and stuff in in there as well and it's
just my absolute favorite co-working
space of all time it's super easy to
book a desk or book a conference room
using the app and it's a great place to
meet up with team members if you're
going to collaborate and you'll live in
different places they've got unlimited
tea and coffee and herbal teas and
drinks on tap and they've also got
various kind of after work events that
happen like happy hours and yoga and a
few other exercise type things and you
can also take in guests so often when
guests will come over to visit I'll say
hey let's pop into wework and we'll just
work from there for the whole day and
then we'll go out for dinner sometime in
the evening anyway if you're looking for
a co-working space for you or your team
then I'd 100 recommend we work like I
said I've been a pain customer for
theirs for the last two years which is
why it's particularly exciting that
they're now sponsoring this episode and
if you want to get 50 off your first
booking then do head over to we.com
forward slash Ali and you can use the
coupon code Ali at checkout Ali to get
50 of your first booking so thank you so
much wework for sponsoring this episode
it's so cool hearing about physical
businesses
um I guess you know these days
really the only businesses you hear
about often the ones interviewed on
podcasts are like online and internet
businesses like oh marketing agency or
PR digital media or content or courses
or any physical software but like
physically designing a product getting
it manufactured and selling it to a
physical customer that's got to feel
pretty good because yeah you do the
online stuff as well what's it what's is
there a difference a different kind of
enjoyment in the two uh from online
sales there's very little enjoyment
unfortunately I I don't really like
online sales although they're a big part
of our business
um there's no emotional attachment to an
online sale apart from seeing the
figures at the end of the day which oh
that's great that makes me feel good
um that's it yeah
um but what is nice is when you sell all
this stuff and you don't see these
customers and I go and visit different
flying clubs or whatever happens to be
or I'm racing model airplanes which I'm
doing this weekend as well and you go to
his club and half the models at this
club are the models you designed and you
go wow look at that yeah yeah that that
came from my pen and I must have come
through me at some stage and that's
pretty pretty powerful stuff really hmm
nice
with I I've just got a few specific
questions about the shop shop stuff
because it's weird for me um do you have
to like buy stock in bulk in advance and
then stick it in a warehouse and then
you're hoping to sell it over time is is
that how it works um it can be it
depends how you do it I mean we ship
from China 40 foot containers
um and if you
look at model airplanes again going back
to the one we just spoke about you can
get uh 550 of those in 140 foot
container so obviously you're you're
having to get containers on a let's say
a monthly basis
um so on that side of the business yes
you've got to buy in bulk because we're
supplying not only end users we're
supplying other model shops as well
around the country and we also license
the product to
um or used to to a guy in Germany who
isn't there any longer but also to a guy
in America so they they actually have
the manufactured at source under our
license and they go out
um so yeah you do have to buy in bulk on
that side of the business on the other
side of the business the shop business
really yes you used to have to buy in
more bulk but because now it's a more
competitive market and you probably
don't have to do that now and also your
website can show Warehouse stock
potentially that you don't have we try
not to do that route we try to have
everything we show on our websites in
stock at least a single item because you
know you get an order for it you want to
fulfill it straight away
um so the only company we deal with
where we have to buy it well in advance
and to the maximum we think we're going
to sell is actually Hornby Hobbies okay
because they're very very I'll put this
on record very backwards in the way they
do business you know they want to know
exactly what they're going to sell for
the year they want those orders in
advance so they can manufacture it which
I I think is the wrong way to go about
things
when when we first moved to the UK I was
eight years old and we were living in
Wiltshire a little town called devises
and there was a toy shop there yeah and
I used to go there and buy these like
mini airplane things and like you know
they would have the whole thingy of like
the Revel paints and the glues yeah the
plastic kits I'll get like a seven pound
99 one for my birthday and that has been
ages like painting the bits and then I
realized you could paint them before you
put the thing on and it makes it way
easier and that was like my hobby when I
was a kid and my brother and I went back
a couple of years ago and the same sort
of same shop was there the same kind of
stuff
um we bought ourselves some Pokemon and
Yu-Gi-Oh cards just for old time's sake
um but yeah
didn't it no I wish if only yeah yeah
there was this is something so nice
about
um just
the the tactile nature of like a
physical hobby which I feel like I don't
I don't really do anymore but also the
visit to the shop yeah it's lovely isn't
it yeah you can talk to them and be like
hey how much enjoyment do you get from
I'll have one of those zero less than
zero so that's the same for me selling
you that product yeah you come into my
shop as I explained before and you ask
about something and I can give you years
years of advice years of help you know
that that that will be perfect for you
and you've had that experience of coming
in and buying why have we decided that
the internet's better hmm what a shame
I think it's it's the same kind of thing
uh
you know if I make a video telling you
to teaching someone the step-by-step
method to starting a YouTube channel
it's very different to sitting down in
front of someone and saying the same
stuff but seeing the like oh in
there you can see the light bulb yeah
you can see kind of the ideas wearing
and stuff which you just don't get over
the Internet
um but yeah internet zero cost big scale
exactly there's lots of you know pros
and cons so so you've got this model
business right now what other businesses
do you have what else what are the
streams of Revenue in your life well
there's all sorts of streams of Revenue
obviously investing as a stream of
Revenue but everything I invest in gets
reinvested anyway
um YouTube obviously is a revenue stream
as well which is shared 50 50 with my
son
um and obviously there's a lot of cost
to YouTube that people don't realize I
mean all this equipment it all costs
money doesn't it and to do a
professional setup we reinvest a lot of
money I don't know what the percentages
are but it's a lot of money
um and that's a good Revenue stream for
me now but it was never started for that
reason you know it was started purely to
pass on these years of knowledge and I
say to a lot of people to give 35 years
worth of life experience you got to look
about 55 and that's just the way it is
yeah
um so it wasn't done initially to to be
a revenue stream but of course it
certainly is now yeah that's so kind of
model business with the manufacturing
arm and also the the Commerce arm and
then the YouTube thing Allah sorry I
mean I guess active income yeah and then
investing and stuff on exactly I'm a
very keen reinvestor so um I don't
really take much out from investing the
only time I really have is when I bought
one of my warehouses because it was
during the.com bubble and I took it out
and Bam it went down and I did it a week
really before the bubble burst it was
fantastic so we're gonna have a little
bit of luck along
um changing gears a bit what is your
take on buying versus renting a house I
like to buy I not only like to buy a
light to buy and pay off oh interesting
yes I know well I'm very um I'm very uh
borrowing avert although we spoke about
boring earlier borrowing for a means I
understand
um the loan that started my business was
paid back within two and a half three
years and it was a 20-year loan so 20
year 15-year loan
um I like to pay back loans I like to
know what I've got I'd like to know
what's mine now
if I did it all again I would be less
alone yeah less um avert to borrowing
money and using money to make more money
so my advice on that or my tips would be
don't be uh loan avert because money can
make money if you've got access to it
you can make money from it but I would
say on buying property for me your key
property you live in buy it own it get
it paid for it can't be taken away from
you you've got such security for you
your family and your wife for the rest
of your life
you know on res a residential property I
buy to rent out or commercial property I
buy to rent out obviously I'll borrow
and I'll let that run the term although
most of my commercial property is paid
off now oh nice but you get to a certain
stage in life I mean again we mentioned
55 yeah then you want to be secure yep
you know all these things as you
gradually secure things off you feel
safer with the future and how things are
going to go
um so although I'm not avert to
borrowing some money for a good project
um I would always Endeavor to try and
get that paid off for me as quickly as I
can my son is the opposite but then he's
24 and has a lot of time to go over
those stages of paying down yeah
yeah that makes a lot of sense
um
what are the so you guys have a
ridiculously enormous following across
all of the social medias which is
fantastic you've done a fantastic job
over the last
two years yeah last two and a bit years
of doing the YouTube stuff um what are
the main
what are the main questions that you get
from from your audience around Finance
uh probably what should I invest in to
make me Rich tomorrow almost you know
okay um and it doesn't matter how much
um we preach or or put over long-term
invest in his long-term wealth it's it's
very hard to get their message over and
I I think with the instant access of
everything to youngsters nowadays it
probably is hard to understand that you
know you've got these small amounts to
gain a big amount in the future so I
always bang on about index funds we've
already mentioned before if you've not
got an index fund running in a nicer
why haven't you you know it is it's one
of the simplest things that you can do
as an individual the most tax efficient
thing you can do as an individual you
are going to be a millionaire if you put
an amount of a decent coffee away every
day into your index fund sorted you know
and that's your safety net
and now again a lot of people say you
shouldn't have a safety net you should
be 100 in on what you're doing but
that's always been my safety net I
always thought from the day I started
putting into an index fund I would never
ever touch that money now
I'm at a stage where I could touch it if
I wanted to I can touch my pensions if I
wanted to I don't need to I have other
revenue streams bringing the money in it
is just there just in case it's almost a
reminder that you made that money you
can make it again
you don't need to touch it why do I need
to touch it
yeah yeah I've been preaching the ISA
Index Fund strategy to my friends in
years this is so obviously if it wasn't
so good it wouldn't be limited to 20
grand a year would it it would be a open
pot but as much as you want it in so
it's just obvious you know you just got
to get on board and take the small
losses when they come keep putting in
don't worry about it forget about it
it's working in the distance when you
don't come out of your house if you own
a house you don't come out of your house
house every day and go oh it's gone down
five percent today yeah of course you
don't because it's still there isn't it
you're not selling it you're living in
it you don't worry about that sort of
thing as you shouldn't worry about your
index funds just keep putting in
historically they've raised
eight percent a year yeah it can't go
wrong with that yeah and if anyone need
the primary index funds we'll put some
of my videos and your videos in the
video description and show notes so you
can you can get a get a primer on them
um
any advice for people who are
who don't have large amounts of
disposable income who think oh I'd love
to start investing but I'll do it I
don't have enough money right now make
more money
you can only save so much money I was
expecting you to talk about tips for
budgeting and stuff but this is
interesting like what do you mean yeah
make more money you know you could save
so much so you get paid a thousand pound
a month for argument's sake okay if you
saved every penny of that that's a
thousand pounds wow that's all you can
do
there's no limit to how much you can
make
so make more money
you know you've got to budget because
you've got a budget if you don't budget
you don't know where it's gone so 100
budget but make more money
how do you do that like someone might be
listening to this thing well okay people
like going to a bar yeah yeah they like
going to a pub well go to the pub but be
the other side of the bar get yourself a
part-time job you've got all the social
side of going to the bar and being in a
pub and you're getting paid for it yeah
you know that's just one example there's
hundreds of examples you know it's you
just make more money
it sounds so simple
it is isn't it though if you think about
it I mean if someone said to you right
it you need to invest five pounds a day
into an index fund and you and some new
Terminator I I don't have five pound
left
in the whole of your day taking out your
day of work you can earn five pounds
somewhere doing something
of course you could it could be washing
dishes in a restaurant it could be
anything couldn't there but you could
earn an extra five pounds
don't spend it put it in an index fund
I can imagine someone listening to this
I mean for the record I agree with your
advice I I I can imagine someone
listening to this being like you
guys you guys are privileged and Rich
and like you don't realize that I've got
a family to feed and like I'm already
working two jobs just to pay my rent
because rent's gone up because inflation
and stuff how can you possibly tell me
to I just need to earn more money
because they're working so hard so hard
because they're service in the debt that
they're under generally speaking
so again if we're into that scenario
start earning more start paying those
debts down particularly the high debts I
mean they're crippling aren't they you
know again if you're earning that
thousand pound a year sorry a month for
argument's sake it's an easy figure to
use and 200 that is going on interest
and payments and you're not getting
anywhere well you're actually living on
800 pounds so get it get it paid down
I know it's harsh yeah it is harsh but
it's also quite simple as well isn't it
so let's say Okay so let's say someone's
listening to this they're like cool I'm
earning a thousand pounds a month right
now
What would
you recommend as like you're a pro like
if you were in that position how would
you go about earning an extra let's say
100 quid a month or an extra 500 a month
well it's probably a bit different for
me and it's different for everyone isn't
it but I would use that scenario I just
said if you'd like going to the pub work
in the pub yeah if you like what
whatever you like to do find some some
requirement from it like I was flying
model airplanes or fly model helicopters
there was an element of of Desire that I
could pass on that skill so that skill
is worth something you know go online
you know there's lots of things you can
do online like copywriting for example
or whatever happens to me in fact you
don't even have to do it just ask hey I
like to do it for you and send it on you
know there are so many things that you
can just learn that small amount extra
and as long as you don't go and spend it
or waste it
nice okay so one big question that you
get is how do I start investing to make
money to get rich tomorrow what other
kind of questions do you guys get but do
you find yourself answering quite often
um
that's quite a hard one I'm looking at
Curtis there for uh a thing I mean most
things most of the things we get are
quite positive and I think you're in a
similar situation it's more of a I
didn't realize that I'll ever go at that
um I think the the thing that we get
that we can't really
get over is the time that yeah everyone
who's young has got time to make money
you know that I don't think people are
aware of how much time they have
but they've got to start you can't keep
asking for advice and not taking action
all right because where's it going to
get you you can read a hundred books but
if you don't take action what's the
point in reading all those books
no point you know so
action is the thing isn't it you know
the answer to most people's questions is
take action do something have a go
nice
uh what's here uh what's your take on
the whole
stop buying lattes from Starbucks so
that you can put your three pound fifty
in an index fund debate well it's not
it's not really that is it that's not
really the thing you know the smashed
avocado on toast it's not really the
thing it's where you're gonna find that
money from and obviously by saying don't
buy the coffee don't buy the avocado it
it that's all on the the saver mentality
isn't it it's like to to save some of
the money you earn well all those things
bring enjoyment don't they I mean going
out for a nice coffee taking the wife
out or the girlfriend or whatever yeah
they're all nice things so I'll go back
to what I said before put some money on
top of what you're earning and use that
that's money you didn't have any money
you earn on top of what you earn is free
it's not free money but you can think of
it's free money use that to invest
rather than say I've got to physically
give up my coffee but having said that
do you need a Starbucks coffee on your
way to work probably not you make an
instant coffee pop it in a cup stick it
in the car you'll enjoy it probably just
as much you know I I buy a particular
instant coffee I quite like and everyone
has instant but I quite like that so
I'll make a coffee when I go to work at
the shop I'll make a coffee I'll take it
with me I could stop I got a cost to
drive through on the way to work well
you know it might sound tight coming
from me but that's four quid I don't
need to spend that in a chance so if you
stop for that you can have a pastry as
well and you've seen what they charge
for loads so you know you don't have to
do these things and actually what are
you giving up yeah you've still got your
hot drink you enjoy yeah
uh have you come across a book called a
die with zero no but I'm guessing what
it's about yeah so interesting book by
Bill Bill Perkins basically about how
people who are kind of aimed at I guess
entrepreneurs uh and people who invest a
lot into their careers where the mindset
of make more money save more money
continues Way Beyond it's actually
useful and actually his his whole
premise in the book is that
provided you've given given what you
want to your kids and given what you
want to Charities you should aim to die
with zero dollars in the bank account
and a lot of people when they hit
retirement age they find that a their
health is already declined and so
they should have spent more money when
they were younger to do interesting
things and B that the mindset of
scrounging and saving pennies
no longer like that that then holds them
back and then and they end up dying with
loads of money left in the bank account
which is time which is money that they
could have not worked for and therefore
saved time assuming they didn't enjoy
their jobs or it was a backpacking trip
they could have taken in the 20s or 30s
or whatever that thing might have been
how do you how do you think about that
balance well it's multifaceted that
isn't it really because first of all
you've got to say do you enjoy what you
do now I enjoy what I do for a living
the the YouTube side of things and
social media with my son I I absolutely
love
um so first of all why would I stop
doing that if that's something I really
enjoy
um so far this year we've been to Las
Vegas
um where we've come and met you today
um I'm doing a bungee jump shortly
because one of our guests gave us a
bungee jump experience
um I'm going to Dubai next month I'm
doing a parachute jump over the Palm
Island or that's the plan with ski in I
don't know if I just mentioned yeah
um I I love doing lots of experiences I
would say if you're an entrepreneur or
businessman
the model I've always tried to do is to
spend a little bit more each year try
and improve your life and your
experiences every year and what I
believe is when you pass away the
experiences and the fun you had are the
things that you're left with so I've
always done experiences always wanted to
race cars I've done that the box is
ticked you know all these different
things are great experiences and you
should experience them without doubt but
dying with zero I don't like the idea of
that I like the idea of generational
wealth and I like the idea that my
granddad said to my dad you're going to
do better than me you know carry the
family name forward and all the rest of
it he said the same to me I've said the
same to my son as well you know I think
that generational thing is great and
particularly when you come from humble
beginnings if you can build your family
wealth up that's got to be a good thing
you know nice how do you think about
like charity and like donating and that
kind of I like to think that I give for
the right reasons but I think we all
give for the reasons that we can say we
gave yeah
um I think Ricky Gervais did a really
good sketch on it in
um what's it extras where he went past
him oh I've only got only got a tenor I
don't really want to give a dinner but
oh that's a tenor right yeah and have
the tenor you know and it was all for
show wasn't it yeah and I think there's
a lot of that going on
um I give what I want to give and I'm
happy to give what I give I don't
probably give enough at the moment but
probably will more so in the future
okay if I see it being used well yeah as
well you know that's quite important to
me I mean our charity as a business is
Kent our ambulance so we'll give to that
um because I think that's a very good
cause and maybe there's a bit of me that
thinks
um I need that one day so a bit of
payback yeah I don't know yeah there's
obviously all these things in there why
do people give to cancer organizations
might need what they develop you know
it's it's a funny thing isn't it yeah
yeah
um
a lot of entrepreneurs
they sort of when you ask them
especially I think above the age of like
30 they kind of wish they'd spent more
time either on their health and or their
relationships as they were as they were
making it big as it were
um do you have any of those regrets um
the only regret I have is I wish I could
have spent more time with my son he's
given me the eye now I can't know where
I'm going with that um and that's
probably why now is such a good time
yeah you know it's he's 24 where he's a
man you know and we we get on well and
we work hard to to achieve the goals we
want to achieve
um but it is a very hard balance very
hard banners I mean the the thing he if
you asked him the thing that I didn't
spend enough time on was he was very
good swimmer and I wouldn't have gone to
enough swimming events to watch him my
flip side of that was always that they
wouldn't give you the time that his race
was on and I wasn't interested in
watching anyone else swim or getting hot
in the environment of a swimming pool
it's not just heart assuming it's
horrible and it's so loud with everyone
screaming their kids coming on and all
the rest of it
um so if they could have given me a time
no I could have gone right I'll block
that in I'll be there I'll be watching
it cheering on saying well done at the
end and all the rest of it
um so that's a slight regret
slight regret but realistically
if you work hard you can gain the
benefits along the way and if your life
gets a bit better over a year then I
think everyone enjoys that hmm
nice
do you think that
um
again so
when I speak to a lot of entrepreneurs
and you haven't alluded to this yet
which is which is interesting but when I
speak to a lot of entrepreneurs they
talk about the importance of work-life
balance
um but they only talk about that once
they're already millionaires
to what extent like we talked about when
you were younger and you know in your in
your teens but to what extent do you
think for let's say entrepreneurs like
your son for example uh or someone like
me and I'm 28 um or people in their 30s
how much how important is this idea of
work-life balance do you reckon
um I think the honesty is as we alluded
to earlier is the important part of that
so as long as the your partner and I
know you have a fairly new girlfriend
um I think the honesty behind how much
work you need to do and how much time
that takes up that's important because
at the end of the day yes it's a
relationship but it's also a bit of a
contract as well isn't it if she's
expecting more from you then you're able
to provide and vice versa then that's a
problem that's where the problem is
going to create so I think open and
honest is is very important
um we used to operate
um the shops initially seven days a week
you know that that's a lot of time when
you're on very low staff and you're
having to be there
um so I I think work-life balance is
very important but if you if you start
off honestly and then every year it gets
better
then I don't think that's necessarily a
problem
um I'm probably going to shock you here
with something as well hello
um when my wife went into labor to have
my son
um I was out teaching someone to fly a
Model helicopter time I said oh yeah
I'll be there I'll be about 20 minutes
half an hour so that was bad really
because I should have been straight
there
um two days after he was born I was in
America competing in the radio control
Model helicopter competition which again
would sound bad to the average person
but that's the commitment I had to the
Hobby and to the industry that I was in
that I had to do that so yeah it doesn't
sound right but that is how it is yeah
and your wife was okay with this well to
be fair she was probably happy I wasn't
around
for those two weeks anyway so nice
um what's it like running a business
with your son
um
it can't be quite argumentative
um but ultimately fulfilling
um we used to our podcast now is called
strike it big it used to be called like
father like son the reason we named it
like forever Light sun was because we
thought the arguments that we had and
the disagreements we had and the
differences between the old and the new
that would make great viewing
uh we ended up finding that the
arguments we had weren't really the ones
that we'd want to air anyway but they
were probably irrelevant or when you
look back on them a day later it's all
like I didn't really matter whether that
was orange or red you know it didn't
matter but we had an argument about it
um but ultimately working with your son
is very rewarding and that would never
have happened within the industry that
I'm in because he has no interest in
radio control models so
um it was a case of we would never work
together but now we do and that's good
nice because because a lot of people
would say oh you know whatever you do
don't go into business with any family
members yeah do you I guess you don't
agree with that advice
um not really no I you've got to be
quite strong
I think because it it could have fallen
apart yeah but it didn't fall apart and
it's like a relationship with a
girlfriend stroke wife you know she's
never happy so it's never like that
great great great great great great it's
a roller coaster yeah and there are ups
and downs and as you as long as you know
ultimately that we're we're we're both
working for the business for the
betterment of the business and when I
suggest Summoners outright ludicrous or
because you're thinking from the Stone
Age dad you know it's it's meant with
the right
passion you know to get the business
forward and you know a couple of days
later Michael may say you know there is
something in there and there's an app
that does that now in a better way and
we can work with this and oh yeah that
works and then that's great another time
maybe that was absolute awful
suggestions but I'm okay with it as long
as it's taken on board and it's like
yeah we'll give it some thought nice and
then that's good
fantastic
um but it is a roller coaster yeah
what do you see as the Ender Game for
you with the I guess the the content
side of the business
um
that's hard to say really I mean the
thing I get from it yeah equally as as I
do from working with my son is the good
comments back you know when you get
comments back you've changed people's
lives that's great when people walk up
to you and I'm sure you've had this it's
like you know I saw that video with you
and talking about this Vandal talking
about this idea or this side hustle and
I've done it and I'm doing really well
Berlin you know I I don't really want
that to stop I'd like that to continue
forever yeah because that's fantastic
isn't it if you can bring everyone up
rather than push everyone down you're
going to feel better as a person aren't
you and that's what I like you know all
you know 99.9 of our comments are a
positive of people that have done better
through what they've done hadn't
realized what they could do or what they
were capable of I mean how many people
don't realize what they're capable of
most
you know it's it's amazing nice so
internet Fame has probably been a
positive thing for you guys I think so
yeah we were we were in a tube station
last night and that was quite funny
because we haven't I'll just recognize
you know people chat sometimes they
don't want to come up to you yeah you
can hear what they're saying oh yeah
that's the guy I learned such off of and
you can hear them discussing it yeah and
you can think that's fantastic not only
has he learned it he's telling them that
that's the guy and now they're learning
it and that's superb yeah it's a really
nice feeling to be able to pass on
knowledge and experience my mentor
um Dave this isn't the guy we spoke
about earliest another guy he died about
or 20 years ago now
he passed on his knowledge for free
absolutely for free didn't even know he
was passing on the knowledge didn't know
maybe he had an inkling I was absorbing
it I don't know
but that was for free that's why we do
all our content for free
one thing I'm curious about so
I'm going to phrase this in a in a weird
way but like from from what you've
experienced and what you've seen
what are the different levels of wealth
by which I mean
you know there's clearly a big
difference between like 10K a month and
like 50k a month in terms of what it
affords your lifestyle but like 50 to
100 100 to 250 250 like uh what what are
the levels with which you see or in in
your in your friends like step changes
and they'll this thing actually improves
your life well I think it's widely
accepted about 80k buys you just a bit
most things you want and you can go
wherever you want you can do pretty much
whatever you want over a certain amount
of time you can do all those things so
if you want to go to Cuba for example
you can fly economy to Cuba have a week
in an okay hotel and all the rest of it
so I I think the first key for most
people is to get to that sort of level
of wealth
um beyond that
it does several things it enables you to
go in first class if you want to
or premium even you know there's a plus
to that and that you know it's
diminishing returns but the comfort is
so much better like for myself when I
first traveled to China and I was doing
my business there I was traveling
economy now I would never go less than
premium because I know that if I go a
better service I can work that next day
that I arrive well when I was traveling
economy I couldn't do that you know I'm
more like this and being a larger sort
of chap it's very difficult so as you
become better off it affords you just
those better ways of doing things the
better Hotel the better travel the you
know some might say the better
experiences you know really because you
know rather than sitting on the beach
watching that guy paraglide along behind
the boat that's you mirror glider behind
the boat
obviously it is a diminishing return but
you can also buy back a bit of your time
as well and I think as you become
wealthier
that that's the thing that you're buying
back you know because you get other
people to do other jobs for you other
things that you'd be tied up doing
anything that takes your time away if
you can buy that time back then that's a
great thing isn't it and we're all on a
limited time scale here all of us and
it's too short you know we all think
we're going to live to a hundred but the
facts are we're not I don't know what
the facts are it's probably 80 something
is it something like that it's not a lot
of life is it really and you've got a
lot of things to fit in
you know I had an accident not so long
ago you may have seen the video
um and that that's it wasn't a life
threat anymore well it could have been
life-threatening it was a punctured lung
and a ribs gone on the back and all the
rest of it it was pretty shocking
um but as I laid there and I looked at
my wife and my son I thought you know
hopefully it's not the last time I see
them but if it is they won't be able to
write on their I wish he'd done more
because he's had a pretty fulfilled life
up to this stage
and I think that's quite a nice way to
be I mean I I also believe you know I
don't like living every day like it's
the last because otherwise you'd end up
with no money doing all sorts of things
you shouldn't be doing but I think you
should live this life like it's your
last life because it is you know so
enjoy everything as you go we have one
guy who works for me he said you should
spend more money you should do more
things you should do this you should do
that and I said but I'm having a great
time I'm 55 years old I can't remember a
year I didn't enjoy so there's nothing
wrong with that is there yeah I take
enjoyment from all sorts of things so
yeah it seems like it yeah
um
there's a bit of a debate well it's not
much baby I'd love to hear your thoughts
on these two two scenarios number one I
don't like doing the laundry I don't
like doing the cleaning of my house
therefore I'm going to Outsource it
because my time is worth 50 Quid an hour
I can Outsource it for 20 quid an hour
versus 100 agree with it versus it
builds character and it's good for you
to clean your own dishes and wash your
own clothes stop being a toilet like do
it yourself when you couldn't afford it
you did it yourself yeah you understood
what you needed to do and when that
person for insurance so they can't come
in you know how to do it it's all about
understanding those those jobs once you
can afford to buy your time back 100
that's what you should be doing I I
think that
yeah wholeheartedly but doing the jobs I
think is quite important as well if you
have the money as a Birthright and it's
gifted to you and you never ever do any
of those jobs and I think you've lost
something there without a doubt and
within my business
um or businesses there's not one job I
haven't done and also use my carpentry
skills in there as well you know so
everything yeah everything I can do I've
done and then when I ask someone to do a
job I'm not asking them to a job of from
a position of I don't want to do that I
hate that job you can do it I'm doing it
saying well I have done it you know I've
done my time it's now your time to go
through that and that's how it is
for someone who does your laundry or
does your ironing that's another little
side hustle isn't it you know it's
something rather than sat there watching
Emmerdale Farm or Coronation Street
which if they enjoy it and they get
enjoyment from nothing wrong with that
but they could be stood in front of
ironing board doing your iron in and
earning 20 30 40 quid an hour and I can
watch Coronation Street while doing that
perfect scenario and then they can
invest it in an index fund that's the
one
um we'll put next to Vanguard and stuff
down below yeah um
what what are some things where
you found that
spending more money has actually led to
more fulfillment a lot of people say
like business class is way better than
economics if you can afford it it's
totally worth it are there any other
things where well first class I wouldn't
say is necessarily better than
um than premium to be perfectly honest
so we flew
um first class back from the states
because virgin offered a a deal that we
couldn't say no to you probably had
similar deals um so we said yeah okay
we'll do it
um but the LifeLock beds for me being
six foot four and a half six foot five
it was no benefit because I was still
cramped up but in a in a premium seat I
can sleep no problem at all
um so I wonder where we're going there
so buying oh um what are what are some
areas in which you found that spending
more money has actually led to a better
experience or more happiness so
I think being able to going back to the
airline thing is is being a do-up you
know but you don't have to go the full
hog you know I I spoke with graham
Stefan recently who most of your viewers
will recognize that name and
he he is more frugal than I am he's
ridiculously Frugal yeah yeah I'm always
surprised yeah he said um because we
said about
um traveling first class and premium and
this and the other and he said I always
travel economy I said really you know
you're worth 20 million dollars why
would you travel that way he said well
the only time I've traveled upper class
is when it costs me less than 30 dollars
an hour to track more to travel first
classes and that's what I I value that
first Class Act
so that's the way he looks at things I
think that's too far I think you know
you can't get there is a diminishing
return obviously we know that but if you
arrive in Comfort that's got to be
worthwhile and also I'm sure you've been
in the Virgin Lounge at Heathrow what
that you know that brings back the the
Jet Set way of traveling you know you go
into that Lounge you're fully relaxed
you feel like you want to get on the
flight you stay in the normal area
you're fighting to get something to eat
your drinks being knocked over by
someone there's everyone's screaming all
the noise so it does afford you certain
benefits that's for sure so spending a
bit of money is a good thing and
rewarding yourself as well you know at
the end of the day having a reward keeps
you positive and focused on what you're
doing you know so again talkative
rewards my son bought um a Rolex because
we got a million subscribers that was
the target if we ever got to that he
would buy that he did and he rewarded
himself and I think if you're building
rewards to your to your business then
that's a good thing cool Final question
um what was it like interviewing and
meeting Andrew Tate amazing yeah yeah is
um you know some people find this hard
to believe but he was a perfect
gentleman
um he arrived early
he gave willingly of his time as much
time as we wanted we thought we were
overrunning and we stopped because we'd
filled a a card up on the camera and we
said oh we filled again you know he's
going to want to go and he said oh
that's fine you know trying to get
another coffee and uh if you want any
more oh yeah so we went for another hour
on top of what we thought he would allow
us
um some of his thoughts and ideas of
course are not
you know great with everyone I
understand that some of them aren't
great with me we did a reaction video to
it and I would say 80 roughly is what
we'd agree with 20 isn't
um talking of hate comments because this
brings some up that of course we had
some from that
um
and people the the biggest comment we
had is why are you talking to this guy
and we get that quite often when we
interview people you know from time to
time you know this is not what we expect
from you and the reply is always that we
interview interest in people
because they're interested not because
we agree with them 100 percent
and if we only interview people we agree
with 100 guess what
would have no guess
you know you take what you can from an
interview as a viewer learn what you can
discard what you don't want you know
throw it in the trash it doesn't matter
but take what you can learn what you can
and that's how you move on you can't be
black or white don't be polarized I hate
that guy so nothing he says is going to
be of benefit to me or the opposite
everything he says is Gospel it's it's
what I believe a hundred whatever he
says yeah you can't be like that and I
think it's a shame when people are
because then they don't have their own
opinions yeah
yeah I'm yeah I'm with you on this one I
think I mean it's the people that you
meet that form your opinion surely yeah
you know that's that's what it's all
about they're the only ones that can
change the way you think the things you
understand
yeah we we we had a bit of a debate
amongst our amongst our team about this
sort of stuff like what sort of guests
do we want to give a platform to
and there was a lot of back and forth
and I really appreciate everyone who
kind of shared shared their opinion on
this but my view was that
if I could get an interview with
Vladimir Putin I would be like hell yes
I wouldn't be like oh this is the sort
of person who's so evil that they cannot
be spoken to yeah uh
and if you can if I'd if you would
interview someone extreme like that then
you know basically reason to have a
conversation with basically anyone yeah
and figure out what you can learn from
them because everyone everyone
regardless of how we think of them has
an interesting perspective to share I
think so you know if JK Rowling wanted
to be on the podcast of course we talk
about her writing probably won't talk
about her trans views but we talked
about the writing it's like you can
learn something from everyone regardless
of what you think about the totality of
their opinions but then some people
would say that like well you're giving a
platform to someone that is spreading
their messages of hate even more how do
you how do you feel about the whole
platforming thing
um or what b d platform and then giving
like
freedom of speech does not necessarily
mean the right to a platform so by
having a big platform and bringing on
someone like an Andrew Tate or whoever
evil person is currently evil and you
know in the
in the media then you're allowing their
message to spread more than it would
otherwise well what's your opinion on
Andrew Tai as this is what this actually
is referring to my opinion is broadly
similar to yours I think 80 very
reasonable uh 20 uh I disagree with
significantly I think the the way in
which he phrases a lot of things Robs a
lot of people up the wrong way and he
knows it does and that's kind of the
whole model my first question to him was
do you believe 100 in what you say and
do or are you just poking the bear his
answer was
I'm poking the bear I'm getting a
reaction so that was the first question
we posed and he answered that honestly
yeah
um obviously he believes in some of the
the the the women's stuff he believes in
and that's what we kicked back on we
pushed back on it on the actual
interview and we pushed back on it even
more on the you know the the follow-up
video we did
um so you know you're going to learn
something from everyone I I I think it's
wrong necessarily the Deep platform
someone
um and I don't are we giving him a
platform I think we're giving people a
chance to um
listen to a good debate and a good
conversation
yeah
yeah I'm I'm wearing control of the edit
oh yeah exactly you know so although
I'll be absolutely honest with you
10 minutes edited out of that one
yeah about 10 minutes for flow so that
was a pretty
everything video nice in fact it's the
least edited podcast I think we've
probably ever done so that shows it was
very genuine doesn't it yeah
um yeah he will he's on run boy yeah all
his fans will find him no problem at all
so yeah
um I think it showed um I think it
showed pretty much the true side of him
which I'm quite proud of to be honest
and it was the last interview with
Andrew Tate before he was uh arrested
yeah and the charges keep changing don't
they so it seems like you do one day if
he's being pinned with something he
hasn't done who knows I mean anyone
who's had the background he's had
probably has a skeleton in their closet
probably
so it's very difficult isn't it yeah
very difficult
yeah I think I'm with you on this one I
think
I can see why people would say don't
give someone a platform but I think the
net value to the world of
exposing people to opinions that they
don't like with appropriate degrees of
preparation yeah and ultimately freedom
in the Final Cut I think is always a
reason to have a conversation I mean we
obviously did Clash on the the woman
side of things because I personally
believe finding the right partner be it
male female whoever you are that is one
of the most important things in your
life that will make you a stronger
person not having multiple women all
that does is spread your time out waste
your time find the right person have a
full loving relationship and that's what
I've had and
that's what I'll continue to have
fantastic Mark I think that's a good
place to end this thank you so much for
taking the time where can people learn
more about you and the work that you do
uh they can come and see us on YouTube
uh just type in Mark Tilbury I'll come
up uh or watch the strike it big podcast
where I think you'll be appearing very
soon exactly I'm gonna do that if you
know thank you so much have a great day
welcome thank you very much pleased to
meet you likewise all right so that's it
for this week's episode of Deep dive
thank you so much for watching or
listening all the links and resources
that we mentioned in the podcast are
going to be linked down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye